time now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week we begin
with a problem that often precedes a
stroke around 15% of stroke victims
first experience transient ischemic
attacks or T IAS a survey published this
week by the American Heart and Stroke
Association found that about one in
three Americans have had symptoms of
such attacks cia's are often referred to
as minor or mini strokes according to
the American Stroke Association they
occur when a blood clot blocks an artery
for a short time the symptoms are the
same as a stroke but usually only lasts
for a few minutes
CBS News contributor dr. Tara nurullah
is here to tell us more Tara what
exactly are these symptoms they have
which as we said are similar to to a
full stroke recognizing these symptoms
is really the key to be able to act
quickly and so things that people can
remember if you feel sudden or
unexpected numbness or tingling or
weakness on one side of your body
trouble with your vision trouble
speaking or understanding language
difficulty walking feeling off-balance
or dizzy or even a sudden severe
unexpected headache those should trigger
you to take action
one quick mnemonic that the American
Stroke Association likes to use is fast
the F stands for face drooping the a
stands for arm weakness the S stands for
speech difficulty and the T stands for
time to call 911 with these mini-strokes
is that they are actually a blessing in
disguise in that they are warning
strokes one-third of people with TI ASO
on to have a severe real stroke within
the next year or so and usually even
within 90 days so really important to
pay attention Tara when it as a regard
to survey when people did exhibit
symptoms what did they usually do in
response so they didn't do what they
were supposed to do in this survey they
looked at about 2,000 individuals and
35% of them experienced one of these
symptoms of a TI a about 20 to 40% of
them chose to wait until the symptoms
went away about 30 to 50 percent rested
and about another 18 to 60% took some
form of medication and interestingly
only 3% called 911 really important to
go to the ER so that you can have
imaging done to determine is it a TI a
is it a stroke to look at what your risk
factors are
to make a plan for prevention what kind
of testing you need and what kind of
medication potentially don't ignore it
please don't ignore it okay up next one
of the most pervasive health conditions
in America asthma may is asthma and
allergy awareness month according to the
CDC in 2015 over 18 million adults and 6
million children had asthma that equates
to almost 8% of the population tara and
asthma attack can be really scary what
what are some of the symptoms that
people should be aware of for anyone
who's ever had it it is one of the most
horrible things to feel like you can't
breathe and so a description that I read
that I really liked is imagine trying to
breathe through a straw that's plugged
up with cotton that's what's happening
to the airways they're becoming inflamed
constricted tightened mucus can fill
them and it's very difficult to breathe
so people can feel short of breath they
can cough they can hear wheezing and
they can have chest tightness or chest
pain the nice thing about asthma is that
although it is a chronic disease it is
controllable for most people by taking
medications by understanding your
triggers it can't be cured but
preparation can help what sort of
preparation preparation is really key
for this chronic disease and so what we
like patients to do is to develop a
personalized written action plan with
their doctor and this really highlights
several things it highlights their
particular triggers and how to avoid
them how and when to take their asthma
medications how to recognize their
symptoms and when their symptoms might
be getting worse and then importantly
what action to take when they do get
worse when to call the doctor when to go
to the ER they use typically a nice easy
format like a traffic signal green
yellow and red that people can
understand these action plan should be
updated once a year and for kids
important to give that to their
caregivers all their caregivers so they
know how to respond we talked about the
personal impact but there's also the
societal impact I think a lot of people
don't understand the financial impact
that asthma is having on the u.s. very
expensive for our country it costs about
fifty six billion dollars a year in this
country to deal with asthma about fifty
billion dollars worth is the
hospitalizations or stays and then there
are the indirect costs of missed days of
school and work about 10 million missed
days of school for kids and 14 million
missed days of work for adults
that's a lot finally time for our
segment practical advice this week when
to take action when having chest pain
Tara for example sometimes it can be
hard to tell the difference between
chest pain that could just be heartburn
and something more serious like a heart
attack it can and unfortunately this is
why a lot of people ignore it they feel
chest pain they take Tom's they say oh
you know it went away it's not a big
deal but the thing I like to tell my
patients is that while chest pain can
come from different causes so stomach
ulcers acid reflux musculoskeletal
concerns lung issues the one you want to
worry about the one that you need to act
quickly on is that is the chest pain
that comes from the heart and you need
to rule that out before you ascribe it
to something else because when the heart
muscle cells die they cannot be
regenerated and so with cardiac chessmen
you need to act quickly we have great
treatments we have great ability to help
people but you got to get to the
hospital fast so people should remember
if they feel a pressure heaviness in the
chest that may be associated with
breaking out into a cold sweat nausea
shortness of breath pain that's in the
jaw or the neck these are things that
should prompt them to get to the ER and
they should do it by calling EMS not by
getting themselves in a car because the
EMS can really treat them right away
they'll get them expedited once they get
to the hospital and if their heart stops
from an arrhythmia or some problem
electrical problem they have a
defibrillators they can use so please
every forty seconds an American has a
heart attack I mean in the time we've
done this segment about six people or
seven have had a heart attack really
important to pay attention wise words
dr. taryn and Rula thanks as always